since I've taken shahada I have led over
12 other pastors into Islam so we're
going to see more testimonies comeing
don't want you to be Muslims for two
reasons let me explain why if everyone
wants to be a Muslim that's the 1.6
trillion alcohol industry gun $500
billion
gumblar adult and pornography gun my
next guest get this I was a pastor for
years um pastor of the church A Large
Church in New York City former ex
Pentecostal pastor of a large church he
was a Christian Pastor for over 10 years
his story is one of the most touching
revert stories reaching over two million
people inspiring many to come into the
folds of Islam submission to the Creator
not the creation what's even more
amazing is Robert West Morland he came
to Islam at a time when he was choosing
his death date I'm excited are you let's
meet Robert and I'll tell you what I'm
really excited the dean center it's
becoming a reality allahar pulling the
resources together making this dream a
reality a mega dawa Center in the United
States allahar this is the future and
it's happening we've got the location
but now we got to get the work going we
got to build the mjid we got to build
the da Center we need you to donate now
not for me not for Eddie but for that
mid for that house of Allah that Allah
would be worshiped in we need to build
that dawa Center where people can come
from across the world and come and get
trained in how to give DAW and
non-muslims can come and learn about
Islam we got to get this done everybody
donate let's do this together it's
happening allahar
[Music]
isum how are
youum peace be with you how you doing
brother I'm doing well today it's a
beautiful day here so I introduced you
as a former ex pastor of 10 years is
that right that's correct yes can we get
into that uh tell us a little bit about
uh what made you become a pastor uh I my
upbringing I grew up in church um
traditional Assemblies of God type of
church Word of Faith and I always felt
uh a Divine pull um and
so my rationalization was I was called
to be a pastor and I was really good at
Gathering people so I was as a kid I was
always good at Gathering little groups
of people and and it it led to adulthood
and so I started a church called uh
Kingdom Culture Center in New York City
uh boasting about gosh we grew from 20
people to over eight different locations
all over the country and uh was being
mentored by top Christian leaders and
for for some reason I just felt this is
not
it and I started questioning things uh
regarding the Trinity and different
religion and just wasn't making any
sense to me I I couldn't understand a
person who went to theology school uh
matriculated in the highest of
Christianity being a bishop a so-called
Prophet an apostle just couldn't have
answers and um Clos the church down
fold eight different eight all eight
locations all eight locations folded W
folded and I went on this journey of
trying to find God and ended up going
into
voodu into what yeah Voodoo
voodo explain un unpackage this for us
all right so vodun or Voodoo comes out
of uh Nigeria uh some of it comes
out of Benin and uh there's something
called orisha worship so it's uh most
people in americaas know it as
santaria and it is uh a mixture of
Catholicism and African Voodoo and so I
started out in santaria and which you
also call palombe which is the worship
of the
Dead uh very very anal istic uh very I
would say dark per se uh just was a
little too dark for me so I said I
wanted to try the lighter version which
was uh which would be call EA which is
also known as is lagba and is LBA
believes in one God but God has
Assistance or partners and the partners
are called the orishas and so it's a lot
of dealing with a lot of sacrifice a lot
of blood sacrifice a lot lot of uh
divination a lot of different uh
manipulating of the elements when we
talk about the elements we talk about
Earth Fire Sky rain all these different
elements that go into it and it just I'm
a
thinker I can go into the highest of
something and my brain starts thinking
well when do we get to God here we we
worship everything else but when do we
get to God here and and in the orisha
tradition uh the God's name is Olu
dumare and Olu
dumare uh is distant off and doesn't
want much to do with Humanity so he
sends the orishas who are his Partners
who take care of humanity for him so
they require certain things and I uh
became what you call a babalao which is
called a father of mysteries and um
initiated several people into the
religion uh several well-known people
into the religion and end up getting
sick um I could get people healed I
could do so many different things for
other people you if you needed millions
of dollars I can get you millions of
dollars I came to me being sick I also
worked in health care and I begin to
take on the symptoms of the patients I
was
treating and that end up being in ICU
for two
weeks and prior going into ICU I kept
going to my shrines and I kept saying
I'm sick what is going on here will heal
you if you do this sacrifice a chicken
sacrifice a goat sacrifice a cow I'm
getting worse and I'm getting worse and
I'm getting worse and so I ended up on
ICU and um really
strange I remember watching two
ticktockers um Maliki
click and Amina rochet
and Amina Roch talked about something
called tah I called it tajun I know how
to pronounce it so t t yes the night
prayer that's that's the night prayer
that's the night prayer and my doctors
were literally giving me because of the
sepsis in my body and the infection I
had literally days to
live and so I
said I'm going to try this tahaj thing
let's see if Allah works and I tried
olari IED all the orishas I done tried
all this other I tried Jesus I done
tried everybody nothing's working right
now let me try to H
it so I tried to hudge it first night
nothing changed second night nothing
changed third night third night is where
something really begin to change I I
would go down to the hospital chapel and
they would let me go down and I would
pray the morning of the third night the
doctor came in and he said we've been
testing your blood our upon hour and we
notice your white blood cells are
normal you're normal I was like okay
this is T HUD okay I'm G to take note
this is T HUD so I guess the T HUD works
I was released from the hospital the
same
morning and as I was driving home I
begin to have
thoughts I don't think Allah did this I
don't think God did this I'm going home
to end this I'm tired I like what you
said because you said Allah they said
God because people think this is another
God this is the Creator God Almighty
Allah in Arabic yes yes and so I don't
think this really happened and I'm out
of the hospital and I'm going home to
end
it and so something said get your phone
go to Tik Tock Maliki click was on Tik
Tock
and I've never in any Tik talk history
has have ever requested to go on
someone's life I said can you give me
shahada an he gave me shahada that was
on June 26
2023 so that was just recently that was
recently yes yeah so for people that
don't understand so tahajud this is the
um Muslims are encouraged to get up in
the night and to pray to the Creator
directly and Alone um seeking His
blessings his forgiveness his Mercy
asking of your needs and whatnot so you
actually heard about this tud from who
again um Malaki click Malik click on so
so you listen to someone from Tik Tok
Maliki click and he's talking about
tahajud and you're like let me give it a
try before that you were talking about
mil you can get uh what were you saying
something about million dollars you can
do oh I can give people millions of
dollars I can get you healed I can get
you anything that you want I can but
when it came to me yeah it was working
if someone says how how are you able to
get if someone wanted these material
things Millions how rituals so what you
do is you do a lot of rituals in Arisha
practice and you can do what I said in
the beginning manipulation there's a lot
of manipulation here if I if if a
particular Shrine for instance uh Arisha
AJ which is the Arisha of money if I
needed a client to have money we would
do so we would ask this Arisha what do
you want it would tell you what it
wanted and then we would go ahead and do
the uh the sh
also we had them taking certain
medicines and incantations and certain
things they had to do rituals baths it
we would get results I would get results
in probably about two weeks with most of
my
clients yeah so so these are working
with the Gin we'd say you obviously know
what the Jin are in fact I worked with
Jin so you were working with the Jin
correct now did you know at the time you
were working at the Jin what you didn't
call them JY what were you call what
what did you what did you identify the
Jin and at that time oh Jin's okay again
there's two different two different
practices I did Palo may yamb we would
call it the eonon or the dead spirits
and so I knew I was working with a a
diabolical spirit and so if you want to
get your bidding done give the spirit
what it wants and it will do what it
wants for you but of course there's
nothing for free and so you you trade
off a little bit maybe a couple of years
of your life you trade off a couple of
different things to get these things to
happen and so with clients uh they would
say listen I I'm I'm about to uh
audition for a movie can you do this for
me sure we're going to we're going to
speak to the gens and we're going to or
the spirits and the spirits are going to
tell us what we need to do and so it
worked well-known people I will never
say their names but uh they were good
clients and uh it was very lucrative and
how how long was this part of your life
going on for after the pastor part being
a pastor how long were you seven years
years seven years so you were a priest
in this profession now yes so you're
technically they have a priest in this
what is it called again AB babala wow
yes and this is all happening in New
York this is happening in New York yes
okay so do the babala also they have um
like a temple what do they call it they
have temples uh it's called oh gosh what
is it called uh they call a temple or EO
or different things like that or El and
so I had several Temple members um to
track back what really made me start
questioning everything was the death of
my adopted daughter who was a priest
she's what you call an oon priest of the
deity of love the river deity uh she was
this is your this is your your daughter
now adopted daughter yes adopted
daughter ADT yes it'll be a year March
3D this
year she was also part of this yes and
she was a what did you call the title
Priestess a priestess she was a
priestess how old was she she was 32 32
okay tell us about this what were you
saying now uh she had staged for cancer
um apparently it was a cancer that was
hereditary her grandmother her mother
died from the same type of cancer and so
we were told by the orisha or by epah if
she wanted to live she needed to
initiate we did the initiations and
everything went worse wait tell us again
those names you said those are the
spirits
the spirits are epah which is known as
the Divinity of uh he's supposed to be
the prophet of U dumare and he's the
it's almost a trinity over there when it
comes to is let me bring it back let me
help you let me let me break it it w
this gonna be very interesting for a lot
of
people so over in ises what you have is
called three major
Spirits uh obatala who I was initiated
to is the the god of creation or the
Divinity of creation then you have the
Supreme Being olodumare and then you
have oruma who is the prophet or the
spokesman of U dumari so now they're
becoming these Spirits are are having
titles that only belong to the Creator
to God Almighty yes okay the the the
ultimate of obviously you know now sh
yes yes yes and so she was promised by
oruma that if she does initiation into
his cult she would be healed mhm she was
also promised by
oson uh who's also known as a Divinity
as well that she would be healed as well
and also egg Bay now egg Bay how do you
how how how are these communications
taking place with her devation it's all
done by devation what is devation for
people that divination board is we have
something called an OP like a Ouija like
a Ouija board
almost like a Ouija board uh devation
board it's called devation board
devation board or an op
op l e
o and so we would Divine we would call
the spirit down and the spirit would
speak through the board wow and the
board will say what you call is 300 and
excuse me 265 264
um signs and these signs of which as an
O as an as a babalau my job is to
interpret the signs and so whatever the
sign fell is the answer and so because
she was my daughter I went to another
babala to do the Divination so it would
be fair and he was accurate he was the
same I knew the signs the signs fell
okay this is what they're saying she did
the initiation she was
literally literally exhausted all of her
funds her husband is actually a
Muslim go figure husband is a Muslim
grew up in Islam um he's doing
everything to try to save her life
nothing's working she has a full
masectomy breast are removed cancer
comes back even more aggressive uh she
goes into uh almost a coma com State and
dies literally two weeks after her three
excuse me three months after her
initiation and so the promises were
never fulfilled and so my thinking is if
they could lie about this what have they
been lying to to me so the the promises
from the Jin the evil spirits they were
never fulfilled never fulfilled yeah wow
yeah so now you're you're like okay if
they're lying about this obviously the
other thing so then that has you then
you hear the tud from the Tik Tock and
now you go ahead and you start
communicating you've have before when
you were a pastor let's take it back
what what was your because there's a lot
of people and I've interviewed different
Christians and one that comes to m is a
senior pastor and he talks about how he
was fed a lot of this stuff and they
were preaching the church that the
Muslims are coming to get you you know
Islam is the enemy what was it with you
now at that time when you're a pastor a
Christian Pastor what did you know about
Islam what was your impression at of
Islam at that time my influence of Islam
actually came more of from the Nation of
Islam Nation um I do have an uncle who
is a Muslim but he does not deal with
the family he's very extreme uh he's
part of an extreme group we we'll put it
like that and so my judgment of Islam
was uh judgmental it was it's they're
judgmental they live on their own they
can't get along with the Jews and that's
how we that's how we're taught so you
know from the Christian Perspective
that's how we're taught they don't get
along with the Jews so you know
proju pro-israel you know that's the
teaching that we we learn
evangelicalism of of Muslims and Islam
so for me it was just like H I don't
know if I would I'm gonna try Allah but
I'm not gonna try this Muslim stuff
because they my thought is like H nah
not for me not for me so even right now
we can kind of connect with what's the
injustices that are going on right now
in uh Philistine and razza you see
what's happening but the programming
that was even at that time this whole
thing even though Muslims if you look at
the history have always welcomed Jews
protected Jews but you were programmed
to think uh even back then that Muslims
just hated Jews oh yes definitely wow
definitely it was a story of of the two
brothers haer uh um haer mother haer's
son he that's what we're taught so it's
we the Bible tells us that you know
he'll be a father of he'll be a great
father but there's always going to be a
fight between him and his brother so
that's just something we you know we
Embrace okay they're always going to
fight so and then you discussed earlier
so you talk about this Trinity um were
there other people amongst your
congregation and others because this is
something obviously it just boggles the
mind the Trinity I mean Islam is
straightforward and clear God is one
worship him alone that's it say message
throughout time it's a chain that was
never broken one God that's it but then
you get into the Trinity it's confusion
got to do a bnch bunch of mental
gymnastics and it just blows your mind
you're breaking your mind trying to make
it work was this was it was this
something uh can you elaborate a little
bit more on this uh you know the
struggle with this as a senior pastor I
never
really preached about the Trinity I just
always preached about God um we saw
Jesus as pretty much as a way shower I
just couldn't un I couldn't as much as I
went to school we really couldn't break
down I always had an issue with the
Trinity because I read that God is one
in the Bible and then all of a sudden
God changes his mind and becomes three
persons it just was a conflict for me
and who is the Holy Spirit how did he
show up like who are you you know you
you you you
know the Bible's very clear from the
Evangel Evangelical standpoint this is
God right here in the Old Testament and
then there's a break and then God all of
a sudden becomes stre three in one it
just wasn't clicking for me and I
remember talking to my leadership staff
talking to my leaders and saying this
doesn't make sense well you got to think
about it this way you're a spirit you're
a soul you have a body you're a Triune
being okay that still doesn't explain
God to
me I this I want yeah this this is very
important so you went to your higher
leaderships and you discussed this yeah
yes yeah I think this is important
people they hear this because sometimes
you think it's just me I can't
understand and then you feel kind of
guilty and then but no this is something
that is just it's illogical it doesn't
make sense and the people who hear this
uh now coming from you a pastor of over
10 years that you were struggling with
it I'm sure there's so many more that
you know the majority of people that it
just doesn't make sense and it's just
blindly submit to this absolutely and
for many people even my leaders had
questions they could they had so they
said just think about it this way don't
try these are the Mysteries this are the
mysteries of Christ you know just accept
it for what it is we'll never understand
it but just accept it but the word
Trinity is not in the Bible well we made
that up we put that together to describe
who God is I said well we're giving God
extra curricular names now and so it it
got me a lot of hot water and the great
part about being um that I had leaders
was that I didn't have to listen to them
I did my thinking for myself and so
doing my thinking I I I begin to explore
other things I was like ah this doesn't
make sense if God is one then how did he
become three and it just became a a a
cluster of this is not the
answer
congregation yeah did you did you did
you have uh some um push back from the
congregation how would they responding
to that uh the great part about it is uh
most of these people that I led into the
congregation I led them into
Christianity so they took what I said
for for word for word it was like it
doesn't make it never made sense to us
we do we'll do what you say we'll go
where you're going to go with this and
that's it was pretty easy to transition
so yeah went independent and then I said
I don't think I want to do this anymore
and we close down what about the concept
of Jesus uh who we love did you know at
that time that Muslims I mean did you
have any idea that Muslims uh love and
believe in Jesus as a mighty messenger
and this concept of not just Trinity but
him being literally God Son of God like
literally not metaphoric Al H how did
that um how did you transition out of
that I remember it took me back uh it's
funny because there were just little
instances where I was actually having
interactions with Muslims and I had a c
an Uber driver he said you know we
believe in Jesus I said yeah okay yeah
he said we believe in Jesus why don't
you come to the master we we'll teach
you more but I had a
moment I was at a um a uh uh what do you
call it a food stand
and I just felt this
presence from this Muslim brother and he
was cooking my food and he says Habib I
want you to know that Allah loves you I
was like I'm a Christian he said okay
Allah loves you I just want to let you
know that I don't know why I felt to
tell you that I was like okay but I
never knew I knew from the cab driver
that Muslims believe in Jesus I just
know the extent he said he you know we
believe he's he's in another time he's
an internal time we don't believe that
he went on the cross and I was like miss
me with that we believe in the cross I I
don't care what you got to say about
that you know we he went on a cross he
died for my sins that's what we believe
and that kind of turned me off but at
the same time it stood in the back of my
head it was a it was a seed it was a
seed planted it to stay there wow
crucifix crucifixion yes tell us about
that now how did you uh deal with
obviously in Islam just like in the in
the Bible says that the father shall not
bear the iniquity of the son nor the son
of the father it's it's actually even
there and this whole concept Jesus never
ever as you know like now that he never
ever said explicitly I'm coming to I'm
God I'm coming to die for your sins and
you explained this to people and they're
like no no no it's his blood we have to
believe it how the crucifixion how did
you deal with that now I'm packaging
that in your mind and some people they
can't get away from it this and they put
it on on they put it on Jesus all the
sins no he died for him oh yeah I had a
problem with it in the beginning I had a
problem with a lot of things in the
beginning um but the Bible actually says
something curse is a man who hangs from
a tree good point
yes
and if in fact there were some things
that just didn't make any sense in the
story uh being theologically trained we
knew some things that went on that we
knew scriptures were added to the
Bible and so from my theological
standpoint I had to reason with some
things and speak to some of my
classmates I said listen bro you know
I'm a Muslim now I'm becoming a Muslim I
don't they don't we don't believe this
this and
that when was this when was Matthew Luke
John written well bro they were written
probably like 60 years after Jesus so
how authentic are they we really don't
know how authentic they are we don't
even know if Matthew Luke John wrote
it and so I me using that rationality
rationale maybe think about it okay well
do I really believe in the cross
because curse is a man who hangs on a
tree and the Bible says that and it said
it in reference to
Jesus and so for me it was kind of easy
to Let It Go but the hard part for me
was well who takes away my sins
now that was the only hard part for me
was like okay who redeemed me how am I
redeemed and so learning some fi and
Akita I got my answers out of that so
that was a good part of you know uh one
thing about Malik click he was like look
you're going to Safina Society take some
classes get you some arita get you some
Fick learn what this is before you even
do anything else and so that was a good
part was getting in depth into that and
learning those truths to help me because
when I had when I started doing daa and
it wasn't on purpose uh people had
questions and I had
answers and that's important right now
and I tell like a lot of Muslims make
sure you have some answers because
people are they have questions and that
was able to help me and so getting away
from the Trinity getting away from the
cross was hard but once I started taking
classes and getting into it I understood
I was like yeah this is a big hoax This
Is A Lie this is really a myth and then
the Bible lets you know that verses have
been added to it so you guys knew that
you knew this at that time as a pastor
of 10 years you you guys knew that this
the B it was been manipulated the text
has been manipulated and Matthew Mark
Luke and John they're actually Anonymous
books this is according to uh Christian
resources and scholarship why do you
think we have so many
translations so many versions none of
them all agree none of them all
agree none of them agree with the the
original manuscripts none of them
actually agree we have there's over 265
biblical
translations
why why so many
and everyone has their own version and
they change and they alter and they say
this and they take away this and they
put we know that so as pastors we have
to uh soothe the ears and give them a
good logical
reason so
manipulation I like what you said there
now where okay you're trying to figure
out who died for your sins and whatnot
there's nobody dying for your sins
self-accountability and now in Islam for
those that don't know you turn to the
the most high the most loving the most
merciful directly without a m middleman
and you ask for forgiveness and God
Almighty Allah is the most forgiving the
most merciful he forgives all
sins and it's straightforward simple
straightforward straightforward and uh
did you ever think now like you know it
often blow my blows my mind especially
I'm thinking about it now with what's
again going on there inza and this whole
propaganda about Muslims hating Jews and
this relationship between the two
Christians and
and the programming with Pastors in
America I don't know if you know when I
had this pastor he talks about this is
very important to know about this
dispensationalism and the Cyber
scoffield and the scoffield Bible he was
a con man cyber scoffield and then they
used this to go ahead and push much of
this uh Zionist propaganda out there
interpreting interpreting certain verses
in the Bible to link it back you know
about this yes yeah now okay yeah so I
think this is um this is extremely
important but now knowing that for our
Christian viewers and friends out there
knowing that Muslims are not it's
actually other people this is with all
sensitivity and love that we explained
this it's actually other people that are
anti uh Jesus are Antichrist Muslims
love Christ that's the the ironic crazy
thing you know uh people try to paint
Muslims as they're the Antichrist well
you can't be a Muslim if you're
Antichrist it doesn't work together it's
oil and water it doesn't mix yeah and I
find that
Muslims sad to say there are Muslims
that love Jesus more than Christians
love Jesus and there are Muslims who
have a lot of that have Jesus as
attributes more than a lot of so-called
Christians do and it's it's interesting
it's very interesting and it it's it's
alarming because I was like wait me
you're more Christian than I am okay
whatever that that's a fact yes yes
the way the way he greeted we'll give
some examples shalam peace be with you
he would say peace be with you uh his
fasting he fasted we fast the way he
prayed and he fell on his face and
prayed to God this is in the Bible we
pray the same the same way we worship
the one God that he worship not him but
the one that he worship we go on and on
yes absolutely yes so uh before we wrap
up let's uh conclude here so you're
accepting Islam your death day so you're
ready to die you're about to die let's
finish off with this this is very
powerful to remind us and the viewing
audience that this life is exceptionally
short we get caught up with this Dunya
and it's very scary thinking about death
you are facing death and many of us now
we might die tomorrow today you not
guaranteed tomorrow and people are not
reflecting and thinking what is the
purpose of life why am I here why is
this so
important it's important because uh one
you have been given a purpose and you've
been given a written Destiny um Allah
himself has called you for purpose and
one of the
things is the power of
surrendering and though I wanted to die
and I wanted to give up I literally
heard a loud voice on the inside to say
do
this go on the internet and do this who
I didn't come on I I had no intention of
being a Muslim I was going to take my my
tahid healing and going back to my
Voodoo and making my money I was good
with that it was good money um but at
the same time there's a power in
submission and surrendering to Allah um
there's a peace that you will have that
you cannot have out of this Duna that
you only get from Allah subhana wa tala
himself and so if you are searching for
that peace
surrender before you think about giving
up get in a place of submission and
surrender and understand that you have a
Creator who says I am who my servant
thinks I am I am who my servant needs me
to be and that is personal for me um
because again I was in a worship where I
was I had a distant God an unknown God a
god with three heads and now a God I
don't have to imagine mhm I just just
know that he
ish I know that Allah is that's all I
need to know and uh I remind people that
Jesus didn't speak English he spoke
Aramaic and he would say Allah Allah
this is the same Creator the same God
tell me before we conclude I was uh
looking at a watching a video of you and
was reacting to a Muslim lady don't want
you to be Muslims for two reasons let me
explain why if everyone wants to be a
Muslim that's the 1.6 billion doll
alcohol industry gun $500 billion
gumblar adult and pornography gun
Hollywood gun interest based loan that
the world Banks rely on gun it's
economical suicide for everyone to
become a Muslim because being a Muslim
makes your Ambitions anti-consumerism
and promotes a dis displine Lifestyle
the thing they want you to do if you
became disciplined you became difficult
to sell and difficult to control and
this is why West media and the elites
are working day and night to program
your children to lose their sense of
Shame and become people who follow their
lasts feelings and desires if you let
them follow their desires you can sell
control and profit off of them and the
only stronghold and defense against this
is hideous ideology in the world right
now is Islam and that's why they hated
everyone who became a Muslim because
their world were crumbles into pieces
talking about why they hate Islam
something about the gambling the alcohol
all of this can you elaborate out that
the industry they would be pretty much
out of business that's why there's this
fight and push against
Islam let's put it like this Islam is is
The Peacemaker and what people don't
understand is that all these vices that
people are looking for they're they're
looking to worship God and they're using
these codependencies
to fill that void of not having Allah in
their life and so the industry was shut
down immediately if if if Sharia law
came in if all these different laws came
in if Islamic law came in the world
businesses would shut down because
people want their vices because it's
their
[Music]
God they want the Corn Hub and the
different things and the alcohol because
it's the medication to help them fill
that void of what they really want and
so the only thing the world knows is to
look towards
devices instead of the Creator and so
when you have that uh that understanding
that the Creator can fill that void you
won't look to those say you won't smoke
you won't drink you won't uh get on Late
Night on on on your phone and doing
things you shouldn't be doing because
you realize that that void has been
filled and that void can only be fil
filled by Allah subhana T himself
absolutely and you said something Sharia
this The Ten Commandments this is God
this is the Divine Law that's actually
mentioned over 200 sometimes actually in
the Bible also right so thank you so
much very very interesting story
inshallah this Inspire so many more
pastors so many more human beings to
look deeply into Islam to think about
the purpose of life and to contemplate
on death and the reality of it coming at
any time and for us to be prepared for
it thank you so much thank you can I add
this as well absolutely we have since
I've taken shahada I have led over 12
other pastors into Islam so we're going
to see more testimonies coming hold on
hold on wait wait wait TW you you've
helped guide 12 other past Christian
pastors to uh Islam submission to the
Creator not the creation yes yes yes
please uh share uh I'll send them away
I'll send them your way yeah we love to
uh to talk with them and inshallah
expose more people to their story this
is great news amen give them my uh peace
my salams I would definitely do that
appreciate you brother thank you salam
alaikum allum I cannot leave without
giving a gift if you're not yet Muslim
and you tune in in to see what these
Muslims are talking about and you like a
free copy of the Quran go ahead and
visit the Deen show.com we'll take care
of the postage and everything and get it
delivered to you and if you still have
some questions about Islam call us at 1
18662 4752 we'll see you next time until
then peace be with you assalam alaykum
we know there are many benefits to the
use of black seed according to the
authentic statements of the Prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon
them that's why I use the black seed by
Tas and Fe 50% of the profits from your
order will go towards establishing the
dean Center the musjid and mega dawa
Center use promo code the dean show 15%
[Music]
off